[Music]
well two and a half years ago I was in a
room with about five or six other
engineers at Skyscanner
and we were tasked with something I
thought should be a pretty simple thing
to do we basically had to figure out
where does our company's revenue come
from right
we thought or at least I thought we
should have a pretty good grip on that
already
what I mean by that is we actually had
to understand how the events that drove
our revenue flowed through our data
platform and ended up in financial
reports and the reason we needed to do
this was that we now had to comply with
u.s. regulations known as socks or
sarbanes-oxley and these regulations
basically mean that you need to be able
to show that no one outside or inside of
your company can change the events that
would eventually show up in in financial
reports in any way that could like
change the numbers or misrepresent the
data now luckily we knew that our
revenue events were basically all from a
single source like they were there was
only one type of event that really drove
revenue and this was like referrals like
when users clicked on a specific
recommendation that we gave them so it
should have been simple right like we
had this one event that we had to
understand the full flow but it wasn't
like it took us weeks to actually get
the answer and have enough confidence in
our answer to make a recommendation on
how can we secure this pipeline and that
really made me pause and ask how how did
we get to this place where no single
team or not even a single person
understood our pipeline well enough or
understood even this one event well
enough to understand the full picture
and the full flow of how it ends up in
financial reports so in this talk I want
to explore that a little bit and tell
you bit about the history of the data
platform at Skyscanner and how we got to
this point what we've done since to try
and course-correct
and hopefully through the lessons that
I'm going to share with you you can
avoid some of the traps that we we fell
into when we were building a streaming
pipeline and I hope if you if you are in
the position that I was in a few years
ago that you would manage to avoid these
mistakes and you and your consumers of
data would be better off for it so very
briefly about myself my name is Herman I
work at Skyscanner if you haven't heard
of us we basically make it very easy to
find affordable flights our mission is
to lead the global transformation to
modern and sustainable travel so we do
that currently by providing you with
very affordable flight options but you
can also sort by like price and comfort
or carbon footprint even and we
recommend you the best flights and from
city to city along with some others some
other things we're very well known in
Europe and in Asia we serve about a peak
about a hundred million travelers every
month so if you haven't heard of us I
recommend you go check it out it's a
very very useful product now our data
story started very much like I think
most companies or many of you here would
find this familiar we had data stored in
all sorts of different places we had
Mixpanel we had Google Analytics we had
something we lovingly referred to as the
cube which was like a big ole app
database hosted on internal servers and
we very quickly ran into two issues with
this system the primary one is of course
when you're looking for a single answer
you want when you have a question you
want to get a single answer not three
different answers to the same question
which happens when you have different
sources of data and so we wanted to
consolidate that and we also found that
the scale that we were not operating at
and the amount of data we were getting
was just impractical to do this batch
loading on a daily basis
and load everything into this OLAP
database so we wanted something that was
more real-time and along with the move
to the cloud about four years ago we
moved to AWS and we decided to also look
into streaming pipelines at the same
time now that's in a nutshell how we
went from from batch to streaming and
this is essentially what our very first
architecture looked like very
interestingly we weren't really sure
whether this streaming thing was going
to stick so we put Kafka in the middle
there and we made an interesting
decision early on to just say that three
different types of data will all go
through the same Kafka cluster we'd have
metrics that go to open TS DB which is
like a time series data based open
source highly scalable page based on
HBase and our users would be able to
query that through fauna and there would
be business events which is gonna be one
man my main focus today which we sent on
to s3 and then that would be variable
through Athena redshift or spark or what
have you and that's more for long-term
storage and then there was also
application logs which we also sent
through the same Kafka cluster but to
elasticsearch and queryable through
Cubana
so our user skid get real-time insights
into how their applications are
performing and and what errors are being
logged and so on and those were three
very different kinds of things with
three different sinks essentially but
they all flowed through the same cup cut
last year and we also instituted a
convention early on that will use
protobuf for everything so everything in
the cluster was protobuf our servers
were able to directly connect to Kafka
and sent better buff there we had an
HTTP API in front that spoke rest so
mobile clients and their suppliers could
talk to this API and then forward events
as pretty buff to Kafka and things were
great we didn't know whether this was
going to catch on and but it did like
very soon we were serving about a
hundred thousand events per second
through this pipeline
and pretty soon people started asking
more of us of course so they asked hey
this is cool we have all this data in
cap canal but actually we'd like to do
some transformations on it we'd like to
add some information to our topics and
so on so we did the typical stream
processing thing we added Samsa which is
a stream processing service software
open source software you can think of
apache storm as a similar thing we don't
know Samsa we found it was a bit
difficult to get set up with that it was
a bit too much to know to actually get
started with Samsa so we made a
templated version of it where basically
data platform users could do a couple of
clicks and change one or two lines of
code and then they have a stream
processing system up and running and
they can read topics and right back
topics - Kafka and this was great this
satisfied everyone they they were
starting using it they were using it to
do merge topics together to split topics
to add more information to topics to add
information from third party api's all
sorts of things were going through Kafka
and to Sansa and it was doing all these
things and at the time there was this
talk about this concept of the single
unified log we didn't really feel like
this violated it because we still have
the single source of truth right if all
the data was still getting through Kafka
it's still a better situation than we
were in before where we had all this
different sources of data you can still
kind of pull the thread through the
whole pipeline with Sansa just being a
part of that so it was fine
life was grand a platform was being used
we were happy it was providing insights
it was driving reports but it was in
that room two and a half years ago when
we were filling up white boards trying
to figure out where everybody came from
going through lots of get up code where
I realized maybe we had become the
victims of our own success because when
we started looking into it we saw that
really like our events were going
through an epic journey so it started
out from the mobile device and then it
would go to the server serving the
referral in this case that server would
send our event through to Kafka as
pretty buff
and then the very first Santa job would
pick that up and maybe add some more
information to it in this case we wanted
some device information topic okay
that's great then another time the job
appeared and picked up that second topic
added some more information to it this
time
maybe we wanted an estimate of the
revenue that we're gonna get from this
event something like that that wasn't
able but we weren't able to get
initially in the first API call and then
another job and another one and another
one I don't know maybe this seems
familiar to you but there was a long
line of samsa jobs essentially all
leading through and then eventually our
revenue event ended up in s3 but no one
really had the full picture of this and
like near the end of the pipeline we had
a deduplication Sam's a job because
after all these network hops we've
probably introduced some duplicates now
we'd like to remove those and then
before we yeah send them to s3 for a
long-term storage and the problem was
there was an automated way that we had
initially at least to know how these
topics were related to one another or
like what the lineage was so my first
lesson here is that Conway's law is true
for data platforms if you haven't heard
of Conway's law
it basically says an organization which
designs systems are constrained to
produce designs which are copies of
their communication structures and I
substituted systems here for data
platforms because when you look at our
revenue pipeline you basically see a
mirror of sky scanners organizational
structure I think there was the first
team producing the event I'm kind of
firing and forgetting about it because
it was their job to send the event and
it wasn't their job to actually make
sure it made it all the way to the end
to archive the next team would pick up
that topic they would add some more
information that they needed and in the
next team in the next team through
basically several organizational hops
all the way through to the archive so
that's why no one really had the whole
picture like it was all going through
all these different teams
and we had essentially created a rather
complicated system inadvertently and
there was a reason for this though like
when we when we created our Data
Platform initially we wanted it to be
self-serve we said you know what we're a
small platform team we're like ten
people in a company of about a thousand
we can't possibly know every dataset
that's gonna be going through our
platform we would simply become a
bottleneck so we like to call ourselves
data agnostic that's one word for it or
having a self-serve platform is another
word for it
but what we maybe didn't realize at the
time is that metadata then becomes
absolutely critical maybe we did realize
it but we didn't realize it quite enough
because when you have a South
architecture your users and you need a
lot of metadata to actually make sense
of what's going on in the system so
let's talk about metadata just just a
little bit because we did have metadata
right but if you were eagle-eyed in that
architecture diagram I showed earlier
maybe you noticed something missing and
I was a schema registry we actually
didn't have a schema registry even
though we used protobuf our if you use
Avro it would be similar like usually
you would use something like confluence
schema registry to keep track of which
topic uses which schema so how did we
actually do that how did consumers know
which schema was being used in a topic
well it was convention very early on we
realized yeah this is going to be a
problem we need to know which topic is
using which schema so we came up with
this really simple convention actually
one engineer came up with this clever
convention which is basically a dot
separated string for every topic so
every topic gets guys kind of looks like
this in the catholic cluster it's like
environment dot service named event name
dot scheme out of message an environment
is something like production or sandbox
and then
the name of the service and so on so
pretty soon we had topics like broad
identity service audit log identity
audit message which is pretty good like
I know it's using the audit message
we're above schema I know which service
is producing this and essentially
through this convention we knew what was
in every topic and how to read it
without having any kind of schema
registry which was really neat that was
nice like it saved us a bunch of time we
didn't have to go implement a new API we
were a small team we didn't have time
for that anyway so this convention God
was really far without doing a lot of
work without setting up a schema
registry or anything like that of course
pretty soon we also had topics like
broad flying circus that up log up work
message raccoon bandits experiments that
banded at Mary metric they tell you a
little bit less I guess it comes down to
how useful of a name the team to choose
for their services in a lot of cases but
at least we know more than we would have
known without this kind of convention so
I'd like to distinguish between three
types of metadata now I'd say there may
be three like these three descriptive
structural and administrative type types
of metadata so with descriptive kind of
metadata we're talking about the
question we're trying to answer the
questions that are basically what does
it mean who owns it what does it contain
where does it come from some kind of
question you're trying to answer with
descriptive metadata
structural metadata is how does it
relate to other data sets how is it
organized how is it sorted or
partitioned and administrative metadata
is more about how far does it go back
how frequent is updated how large is it
how complete is it like these are all
really important questions and what we
found was that we kind of covered the
first one we had some descriptive
metadata by virtue of using the topic
naming convention we have a little bit
of structural metadata because we used
protobuf if you if you're not using a
structured schema like read about for a
bro I highly recommend you go out and do
that and get yourself a raise but we
kind of had that
but we didn't know how datasets related
to each other so we had that key
component of structural metadata that
was just completely missing
administrative metadata if we had it we
weren't exposing it to our users so you
could may as well say we didn't have it
but you know we did we didn't know if we
really wanted to find out we could find
out answers to some of these questions
so the second lesson here is that
metadata is absolutely critical we
started asking our users to manually
enter the lineage before saving advances
to s3 and ideally we would have done
this from the start of course ideally
this would have been completely
automated as well but it wasn't and we
were now like trying to course-correct
and it's better to start late than not
ever and tools like the schema registry
would have been a start but it's not the
cool solution like if the schema
registry itself also only tells you
about the kind of schema that's in there
it doesn't give you all three types of
metadata you kind of have to think about
how you're gonna provide that to
yourself and to your data platform users
so I'd like to compare this to this xkcd
comic which many of you may have seen
already of characters going thru
Jurassic Park right so I'll quickly
explain like when when characters are in
the same scene the lines are close
together when they're not in the same
scene or if they're far apart for some
reason they the lines are further apart
and time is on the x-axis so as time
goes on you can see the Raptors for
example start out together and then they
split apart they don't make it all the
way through as the some of the
characters also not make it quite all
the way through as you might expect in
Jurassic Park
but yeah it's like a nice view of
basically what's happening in in
Jurassic Park
and in this analogy I'm basically saying
topics in Kafka are a bit like this they
can start out together anything it gets
split up or they can get merged halfway
through or they some of them make it all
the way through to the archive some of
them don't and we thought our pipeline
looked like Jurassic Park but really it
looked more like primer everything
starts out completely fine like with
three characters
as time goes on you start time-traveling
and it just loses all semblance of
traceability and your audience are left
scratching their heads so the situation
would have been better with metadata but
that's not the full answer either
because our users still evolved a really
complex system while we were kind of
looking away and by having very few
restrictions on what you can do and what
kind of transformations you're allowed
to do we kind of harmed the usefulness
of our platform in the long run so our
system was very simple but the data was
not and that brings me through the third
lesson which is that data engineers
control the plotline so what I mean what
do I mean by this now we've all heard of
spaghetti code it's basically when you
have code that's really hard to trace
it's crossing across different files and
different methods and you can't really
follow what's going on now spaghetti
code is very easy to recognize but in a
data platform you don't actually see it
in your codebase you could have a data
platform that has very very modular code
a shining example of clean modern coding
designs but meanwhile your users are the
ones producing the spaghetti and their
data is actually where the spaghetti is
it's not always easy to see but the
controls that you put in place on your
users and you really have to think about
this very carefully early on what
controls are you gonna put in place to
make sure that you end up with a plot
line that looks more like twelve Angry
Men rather than primer now I enjoyed
both these movies I recommend you go out
and watch them if you haven't but I
would rather have a plot line like
twelve Angry Men for my data platform
then for like one like primer right so
we kind of knew what the problems were
we knew that Sam's or processing jobs in
general we're causing us issues because
they were on the path to our data Lake
to long-term storage
and this complexity wasn't even the only
problem we had other things to like we
knew that if one of these Sam's our jobs
failed for whatever reason then the
topics that they output would also
impact downstream Sam so jobs and users
would come to us and say hey this topic
disappeared where did it go
where do I find the owners and we would
kind of say like no it's you know we're
data agnostic we don't know so that was
not a great situation to be in but also
moreover like when any of these Santa
jobs had a bug which we didn't ever
never-to-be happen from time to time
they'd be producing data that would be
incorrect and someone would discover it
after some time like yesterday we still
saw a talk by Great Expectations which
could definitely like help with this
kind of problem but the fact remains
like when we discovered a bug like this
we would then have to replay data
through the pipeline somehow without
affecting all the other sounds of jobs
that might be depending on these topics
and we don't really understand what
might be the implications we don't
understand what this could mean for
duplicates necessarily especially when
you're talking about replaying weeks of
data you could have all sorts of
unpredictable problems so this was
affecting our ability to really analyze
the data and to issue reports reliably
and we decided you know we're just gonna
do away with that that whole that whole
link we're gonna say let's go straight
for my HTTP API to s3 you may have know
you may have noticed that the servers
are now also competing Oh communicating
with the HTTP API like that was
something we did some somewhere in the
middle because we realized that when a
lot of servers been up a lot of
containers they all open connections to
Kafka and you run out of file handles
and that caused problems for us so now
everything was going through an HTTP API
and we were enforcing protobuf
essentially which is good but now we
kind of want to go straight from that
API to s3
and you can't just do that because if
you were to simply write every request
you has to directly you'd get very very
tiny files you kind of need some sort of
cue in the middle as you as you all
probably know so this is kind of what we
did we decided okay we'll split our HTTP
API
we'll make it go into two routes we go
one way is the Kafka route where we go
with metrics and logs and events and and
the other route would be Kinesis and
that would be consumed by flink and
think we'd be writing it to s3 every 15
minutes now we chose Canisius not
because it's necessarily a better choice
than Kafka it was easier for us to roll
this out in multiple regions it's kind
of its managed for us and flink
is a good abstraction layer it's
stateful it allows us to do this writing
to s3 in kind of an easy way without a
lot of overhead and what you might
notice you is that there are no
transformations on this this is a lot
more like twelve Angry Men it's just a
straight line and this is kind of how we
went from from streaming to both batch
and streaming like you may say these are
mini batches because we're writing them
every 15 minutes but the point is there
are no transformations and they're all
we're all kind of going through the
archive directly of course though people
still needed transformations so we said
that's fine you can do transformations
you just have to do them on the archive
and we specifically said you can use
spark for this but we learned our lesson
we said if you're going to do a
transformation you need to register that
somewhere and we have this data catalog
where we register transformations so we
can understand the flow of data at this
time we also favor configuration over
code whenever we can for transformations
so that it's easier to track this kind
of thing and we even added some some
nicer things to this catalog like
measuring the completeness of the data
so we can have some more metadata on it
in this way and we're hoping to even
verify ownership like in our topic
naming convention we kind of relied on
honesty like services really you
the real name or name we could find
somewhere in a catalog now we have the
opportunity to really verify this with
excitability tokens or something along
those lines so this also solves the
replay problem some extent because
transformations on the archive are
repeatable and this is something kind of
fundamental with streaming pipelines
that we don't often talk about I think
when you do it
we need your transformations on s3 and
you had a bug in your spark job for
example you could fix that bug and run
it again on the same time frame and the
data would be replaced in place and you
don't have to worry about how it's going
to affect other jobs necessarily because
you know which jobs need to be retried
you read trigger them again you don't
have to worry about duplicates being
introduced or anything like that so it
was a bit simpler to manage the
correctness of our reports at least in
this way so the the lesson here is that
repeatability is important now yeah like
I said streaming pipelines kind of have
to choose between doing replays which
could be complicated and accepting
errors is permanent now I'm not saying
it's impossible to do replays you
definitely can you just have to think
very carefully about how you're gonna do
them without introducing duplicates I
think if you have a clear partitioning
scheme from the very start and you know
how you're gonna do replays in a way
that's safe and predictable then it's
totally fine but we chose to go
different routes and kind of just avoid
that problem altogether so you really
need to think quite hard about how
replays will work and in batch
processing transformations can run
anytime and you can do them again any
time and it's just simply a bit easier
to manage
so going straight to the archive kind of
gave us a mix of both worlds because to
be clear we were still sending our
business events to Kafka as well so you
can still get those real-time metrics
you can still derive metrics you could
still run your Sam jobs that was also
fine so you can get those
transformations but we just said please
don't send those to the archive and we
do reports we want the data to be
correct and reliable and we need to be
able to fix it in the future if
something was wrong so we kind of get
the benefits of both but also the
downsides of both one downside is not oh
now we have to maintain two code bases
to do transformations and it's a problem
we haven't really solved yet to be
honest we do spark transformations and
we still have Samsa transformations to
code bases are pain we're thinking spark
streaming might help here but honestly
it hasn't been a big problem like most
of our use cases for transformations
were actually meant for the archive and
you kind of just need it there most of
the time so to quickly recap everything
the takeaways are that Conway's Conway's
law is true for data platforms metadata
is very critical data engineers control
the pot line and repeatability is
important now the lucky thing for me is
that because Conway's law is true how
these rules apply in your specific case
will be different it will be based on
what your organization looks like and
what your structure looks like in our
case we decided to split and create this
kind of deal batch and real-time
architecture known as lambda
architecture that worked for us it might
not work in your case but it's something
you need to consider and I will say
though that I think no matter what the
size or or makeup of your organization
having a self-serve data platform makes
a lot of sense as your organization
grows you'll you'll become a bottleneck
if you don't allow your users to use
data themselves make transformations
themselves do their own thing without
you being the middleman as a data
engineer and then as an engineer you
need to be conscious of the controls
that you put in place and this isn't
necessarily only a lesson for data
engineers it's anyone building pipelines
anyone
doing transformations needs to be you
need to be aware like having too few
controls in place could really impact
the quality of your data in the end
could really impact the interpretability
of the data in the end but having too
many controls good harm adoption on the
other hand so my recommendation here
would be to aim somewhere in the middle
and kind of tighten the screws as time
goes on get people using your platform
with some restrictions and then if you
see things like they're losing the plot
so to speak you can kind of add some
more restrictions as necessary and so
yeah then repeatability is important but
often overlooked and if like in our case
your streaming pipeline is also on the
path to your data Lake you should really
consider what happens when things go
wrong like that that is something really
important to think about very early on
and we decided to go with this batch
architecture because that simply avoids
the problem maybe that's a good option
for you as well maybe not but yeah if
you take these lessons to heart and if
you do things right then I hope with
some luck you won't ever find yourself
in a situation like me where you're
trying to figure out where your
company's revenue comes from and that's
me thanks thanks for the talk what is
your data catalogue look like it's a
pretty simple database right now where
we just capture some information like
yeah it's it's basically a REST API
where we recapture this it's kind of
internal still pretty new to be honest
but I
yeah what would you like to know about
the data catalog specifically like yeah
I think there's a lot you could do in
this space we're kind of still feeling
out how to do that exactly we we we have
like a REST API where we register at
least the the very basic transformations
especially merges of topics we're
interested in capturing that
we we have a rule actually like in our
in my diagram it took like 12 Angry Men
in reality we actually have something
that's a bit more like an end to one
mapping like you're allowed to merge
topics from many to one before they go
to the archive or before we commit them
permanently to the archive and that's
configurable through this wrist API so
that's that's kind what it looks like
but yeah still a lot of work to be done
on in that area
we also yeah we also have something like
I mentioned about completeness that API
is able to actually tell you over a long
time span how compete was the data based
on like good for example we measure like
how many of the events were received on
the one end how many we received in the
archive and then we can tell you okay so
this data set is 99.9 percent complete
you can probably kick off your reports
or kick off your transcript
transformations yeah that's also a REST
API that we provide I have seen that
every events are coming into the HTTP
API yeah and it's quite a tricky just to
create API that suits mobile platform
desktop platform Elm Diller and all the
rest do you some kind of open source
solution or you've developed it by
yourself with maintain by yourself how
it's good that's a good question we did
actually develop this on our own
there are open source solutions out
there now I believe I think confluent
offers one I'm not sure but we did
develop our own solution written and go
in this case and it's it's not that hard
I would say to do because it's stateless
and it's basically only taking JSON and
converting it to protobuf which is not a
very expensive operation necessarily we
did have to optimize it quite a bit for
the kind of scale that we're dealing
with but it scales horizontally because
it's not stateful it's it's not that
hard it's maybe not as hard as it seems
but it did buy us a lot in terms of like
redundancy across regions in terms of
consistency of our data because now we
can put some basic checks in place to
validate the quality before it goes into
Kafka
things like that it is definitely worth
doing even it is if it is a lot of work
why flink versus using fire hose to
write to us 3 a good question um fire
hose is essentially limited to one
schema which is a huge limitation like
we had hundreds of different schemas we
did look into fire hoses initially
because that would be very easy and nice
but because I think you could use many
different fire hose streams and then
kind of get around the schema issue but
we went the route of having one single
Kinesis stream and then a Kinesis
solution I will make yeah exactly you
need to land out something for fires to
do finally like another transformation
it certainly could work we did explore
it as well
there is something I'd like to mention I
guess like Canisius analytics is also
you might know it as something you can
run sequel queries with but you can also
run flink on it now we intend to move to
that as a fully managed solution of link
right now it's running on EMR so then it
would actually kind of be very automatic
for us but they just haven't updated to
the version we need yet so yeah very
quickly how's your experience with flink
as a solution for like stateful
processing in overall pretty good it's
been solid like we so we've this is all
kind of new stuff like we've been using
it for maybe four or five months now
haven't had really any issues other than
with EMR itself like maybe the master
node falling over and then we have to
restart the cluster but flink itself has
been very stable like we expected it to
run out of a memory for example if we we
had a big backlog of messages but it
didn't like it was able to actually like
write faster disk and then flush when
appropriate and so on so yeah our
streams is pretty good I'd like to talk
more about that if you want to come to
office hours
[Music]